-Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show"!
You're here, you're watching,
I appreciate it.
Guys, it seems like there's so
much going on right now.
The supply chain is still
causing problems.
Paul Rudd was named
"Sexiest Man Alive".
[ Cheers and applause ]
Adele debuted a new song.
[ Cheers ]
And Arby's just announced two
French fry flavored vodkas.
[ Laughter ]
There's just a lot to go over.
So let's just jump in and cover
it all at once.
It's time for a "News Smash."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
First up, the supply chain.
President Biden just met with
several companies
like Walmart, Target, and FedEx
to discuss solutions
and it's not looking great.
But, you know
who is looking great?
Paul Rudd.
[ Cheers and applause ]
He was named "People's"
Sexiest Man Alive. Good for him.
He's universally beloved.
He makes us all laugh.
But if you prefer someone
who's universally beloved
and makes us all cry,
there's always Adele.
[ Cheers and applause ]
She just debuted a new song
in an Amazon holiday commercial,
and it's fantastic.
The song is called "Hold On,"
and it's all about
not giving up.
But if you want to give up,
why not try Arby's new
French fry vodka.
[ Laughter and applause ]
They're releasing two bottles,
and apparently,
they have the same
"flavor profile"
as their curly
and crinkle-cut fries.
[ Laughter ]
I don't understand
how that would even work.
Speaking of things I don't
understand, the supply chain.
[ Laughter ]
Shipping, trucking, inflation,
all of it has people really
stressed out.
But it's going to be okay.
Just take a deep breath,
pour yourself some wine
and listen to Adele.
[ Laughter ]
The new album drops next week.
Her first album was "19,"
loved that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Then "21," loved that.
Then "25," and now "30."
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're really -- we've really
seen her grow up over the years.
You know who hasn't grown up?
Paul Rudd.
I mean, look at the guy.
[ Laughter and applause ]
He -- he only gets better
with age.
You know what doesn't
get better with age?
Arby's vodka.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I -- I just don't get it.
I mean, from the vodka itself
to the label,
all the way to the bottleneck.
[ Laughter ]
Everything's
completely backed up.
So it'll affect prices.
And if you order
anything online,
be prepared to "hold on."
[ Laughter ]
In conclusion, what a guy.
Time to cry,
low supply,
just why?
[ Laughter ]
This has been a "News Smash"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Thank you.
Hey, here's some COVID news.
Apparently,
the U.S. government
helped Moderna
develop their vaccine.
And now they're in
a patent fight
over who deserves credit for it.
Yeah, even crazier, they're
going to settle it on a --
with a rap battle on "VERZUZ."
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile,
there's also a battle
over the Johnson & Johnson
patent because
nobody wants to
take credit for it.
[ Laughter ]
No, it was the other Johnson.
Some business news.
YouTube just announced that it
is hiding dislike counts
on all videos.
That's right.
Now instead of clicking
thumbs down,
people will just write "dislike"
in the comments.
[ Laughter ]
"Not for me."
Yep, no more dislikes.
Instead, YouTube will provide
the user's home address
so you can just tell them
in person
how much you hated their video.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, dislikes are annoying.
They're right up there with
people who comment "first!"
It's like,
"Oh, it's just stop."
Well, the holidays
are coming up,
and I read that 'cause of the
tight labor market,
there's actually a shortage
of mall Santas.
[ Audience "aws" ]
Yeah, malls are desperate
to find Santas.
Today, in fact, Macy's put out a
bowl of whiskey
outside the store like they were
trying to lure a stray cat.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-Putting a bowl of whiskey
out there.
-For Santas.
Yeah, it's hard to recruit
for the job,
because you can't just
walk up to people like, "Hey,
you're built like Santa Claus.
Do you want to --"
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
No mall Santas.
Instead,
it'll just be an elf saying,
"Whatever you want, it's on
Amazon. Merry Christmas."
[ Laughter ]
Hey, get this,
The Hallmark Channel
is holding a baking contest
and the grand prize is
a walk-on role in a Hallmark
original movie or $5,000.
[ Laughter ]
Even the director of the
Hallmark movie was like,
"Take the money!"
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, for 5 grand, you can
shoot your own hallmark movie.
-Yeah.
-Hey, here's good news, the
North American Meat Institute
said it will reach
Paris Agreement
emission targets by 2030.
When I heard,
my first thought was,
"There's a North American
Meat Institute?"
[ Laughter ]
Sounds less like a real
organization and more like
something you'd read
on the shirt of a dude
at CrossFit.
[ Laughter ]
It's a long walk
but it's worth it.
I like that joke. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
according to new research,
it's perfect --
the perfect time to go to bed
for your heart's health is
between 10:00 and 11:00 P.M.
Probably explains why NBC ran a
promo today that said,
"Forget your heart and catch an
all-new episode of
'The Tonight Show.'"
[ Cheers and applause ]